let's make some delicious garlic shrimp
first we gotta mince lots of garlic
listen i don't like mincing garlic i
gotta be honest but i love this thing
makes it really quick and easy and my
fingers don't smell like garlic
afterwards feels like i'm playing with
hot wheels life is good in this moment
also thought it was gonna be hard to
clean but it wasn't so that's nice to
your pan add some oil minced garlic
green onions let that cook a little bit
until it's nice and fragrant add the
shrimp fish sauce oyster sauce toss that
up add some black pepper freshly ground
some butter give it a mix i added the
butter in later so i wouldn't burn it
top with parsley i like to eat it with
rice clear the center flip a bowl over
the pan that rice is going to soak up
all that garlic butter on the bottom of
the pan if you want squeeze some lemon
over it so delicious such a crowd
pleaser you can eat it with pasta
instead of rice or dip some bread in it
if you like it saucy you can go ahead
and mix it all up together and people
can just scoop their own portions enjoy